so the bite Administration has made a
practice now for over two years of
picking federal judges based on the way
they look
based instead of their competence and
the confirmation hearings for these
judges are as painful as you would
expect they would be contagi brown
Jackson famously said she can't Define a
woman and yet she's among the Supreme
Court
another judicial nominee in Washington
state couldn't explain what Article 2 of
The Constitution is must be a federal
judge then there's the latest a guy
called Cato Cruz is Biden's nominee to a
federal judgeship
how did he do in the hearings well
here's a clip
tell me how you analyze a Brady motion
how I analyze a Brady motion
yes
senator in my uh four and a half years
on the bench I'm not don't believe I've
had the occasion to address a Brady
Motion in my career do you know what a
Brady motion is
Senator in my time on the bench I've not
had occasion to address that and so uh
it's not coming to mind at the moment
what a braiding motion is
right he later guess it must have sent
you with gun control because President
Reagan's Presbytery was called Brady and
he got shot and his wife became a gun
control Advocate right so this is not a
small question to miss the Brady that
Senator Kennedy referred to emanates
from the Supreme Court case that
requires government to turn over
exculpatory evidence to the defense
that's the core of our justice system by
the way that's the rule the doj violated
in hundreds of cases of January 6th
defendants this guy who wants to be a
federal judge had no clue what it was
that's a deal Ender right there no you
can't be a federal judge sorry go do
something useful with your life you
can't be a judge it probably will be Ned
Ryan is CEO of American majority he
joins us tonight and Ryan thanks so much
I don't know what is going on but when
they start look it's fine if you have
flaky sociology professors or
administrators at Stanford or whatever
who cares but airline pilots heart
surgeons and federal judges like why are
we allowing this
well I I think this is the entire point
for progressives I mean you have a judge
that doesn't know article two or Article
5 of The Constitution this gentleman
that doesn't know the Brady motion the
Brady rule again as you pointed out
where hundreds if not thousands of
Americans are being denied this basic
right because of their political views
well there are a couple things going on
here Tucker first they are diversity
hires they're hoping to skate by on
their skin or gender or sexual
preferences but it really does highlight
that the abide Administration whoever's
actually running it is putting up
activists masquerading as judges because
the whole point is to get more votes to
rubber stamp the left's social and
political agenda but even more so Tucker
as you think about progressives they've
always viewed the Constitution and the
laws obstacles to be avoided but even
more so maybe dismantled so why would
you even bother knowing about it because
you're not going to pay attention to
them anyway and the whole point of
progressivism from day one and until
today is to bend to dismantle the
original intent of the Constitution
separation of powers and all these other
things that were put in place by our
Founders they don't care about them they
don't want them so why should you bother
with them because you're never going to
implement them because they're more
series of suggestions that you're trying
to avoid
well here's why because if you don't
have the rule of law an equal
application of the law you don't have
civil rights and I thought they were for
civil rights so I don't know why people
like Lindsey Graham vote to confirm
judges who don't know anything about the
Constitution like what is this
because from the very beginning
Progressive statists have been have been
the enemy of basic civil rights of the
rule of law of property rights of all
these things and over the last hundred
years it's like their colors are coming
out more and more and it's getting
harder and harder to hide that but this
has been the whole point of
progressivism from day one Tucker they
have no intention of any of these basic
rights their goal is the administrative
State and quite frankly ultimately it's
it's power
authoritarianism and so the Constitution
and the law are to be disregarded they
will make of them whatever they want
them to be to achieve whatever they want
the the point is not the original intent
of the Constitution the goal is not the
rule of law it's whatever they can make
them to be to achieve what they want and
here we are
we're so mesmerized by watching them
tear down our institutions we don't
think enough about what they're going to
replace them with and we should
authoritarian exactly thank you so much
thanks Tucker subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight